pas le temps de jouer au pas le temps je
ne suis qu'un l'âge j'ignore le monde
ses idéaux et comme un porc sans roulage
une programmation éclectique pour la
salle de la tour
après cinq ans d'absence un nouveau
festival va voir le jour à voisins le
bretonneux
l'été dernier on s'est dit pour qu'on
ferait pas quelque chose allez on remet
ça cette année on a décidé de mettre les
boîtes c'est à dire que la salle de la
tournelle reprend l'air et cette année
on veut mettre un peu plus de puissance
donc voilà pourquoi on met les ouates de
scène du reggae du rock du punk une
journée de concerts et une tête
d'affiché à l'acte rab
[Musique]
et vite
ça va
à l'altra bhl qui cartonne en ce moment
lui depuis 20 ans depuis les scènes
françaises
voilà qui propose vraiment cette musique
natural trance donc dans l'univers un
peu techno mais vraiment avec les
instruments jouent avec des vrais
instruments qu'ils ont leurs patins eu
assez unique et je pense que voilà le
public commence à la bien connaître ce
groupe et à le suivre
c'est vraiment enfin l'ambiance en
concert est excellente
[Musique]
des groupes indépendants et des groupes
locaux ils seront une dizaine à voisins
le bretonneux
rendez vous le 1er juillet pour près de
10 heures de concert